here in Katz deli the iconic restaurant  where meg Ryan had her famous orgasm  scene oh it's great to be here a little  piece of film history let's see if  you're capable of an oscar-worthy  performance if you can recreate the  scene take another nailing okay as soon  as she's done with her fake orgasm or  you look over there and say I'll have  what she's had action need you to outdo  meg Ryan yeah is it hot in here she's  happy  we have a surprise for you guys since  you participated you were such good  sports we are giving you two tickets to  the Oscar red carpet experience at the  Oscars you'll be on the side and the  bleachers watching all of your favorite  celebrities